ORI KASHI: Hi.
I'm Ori Kashi.
I'm a product manager
here at Google,
working on the databases team.
Joining me today are going
to be Doug and Shashank, who
are going to help me explain
how Cloud SQL for SQL Server
can be set up and
provide value to yourself
and your organization.
And all the familiar
tools that, today, you're
probably using with
SQL server on prem
that you can also use
with our Cloud offering.
We're going to
kick it off talking
about an overview of the
different capabilities
and features that Cloud SQL
for SQL Server provides,
and some of the
considerations you
should have when
setting up the service.
Then, I'm going to focus in
on some more complex topics
that we generally get a
lot of questions about,
such as replicated
persistent disk
and how that plays into our
high availability strategy.
Then, we're going to hand it
over to Doug and Shashank,
who are going to
share with you a demo
about transactional replication
and how to set that up.
Finally, it's going
to come back to me,
and we're going to talk
about the next steps of where
Cloud SQL for SQL
Server is going
and some considerations about
everybody's favorite topic--
licensing and pricing.
OK.
So if you're not familiar,
Cloud SQL for SQL server
is one of three database
engines that we offer as part
of the Cloud SQL portfolio.
It was released to general
availability early this year,
and provides a fully
managed solution
that will provide common
tasks and reduce overhead
such as upgrades, backups,
patching, and other key aspects
to managing SQL Server.
Today, we have SQL Server 2017.
Four additions
that are available,
such as Enterprise, Web,
Express and Standard.
It's fully compatible
with the tools
that you're familiar with
like SQL Server Management
Studio and PowerShell.
And we can automate a lot of
tasks via the APIs and GCloud
commands, as well as the console
UX you may be familiar with--
just as you would with
both PostgreSQL and MySQL
as part of Cloud SQL.
We show this map every year.
And every year, this
just keeps growing
in terms of the number of zones
and regions that are available.
And the key takeaway
here is that Cloud SQL
is available in
all these regions,
and SQL Server is no different.
So you're able to have it,
Cloud SQL for SQL Server,
in any of the regions
that you are located
in that GCP is expanding to.
And this map will just
continue to fill out
as GCP continues its growth.
So what you see here is actually
the cloud SQL architecture
that's common to all of
our database engines.
And I thought I'd take a
minute just kind of diving
a bit deeper so that everyone
can understand what's actually
going on under the hood.
And so on the left-hand side,
what you can see here is,
actually, each instance has
their Compute Engine VM--
just like you would in GCE--
that has a Cloud SQL image in a
container with both SQL Server
and all of our management
agents running on top of it.
This includes everything that we
use for monitoring, management,
connectivity, and the like.
Powering that, of
course, we have
our network layer, which is
common to all Google Cloud
products, as well as Persistent
Disk for storage layer.
And so whenever we
go and actually do
a deployment of SQL
Server, what we're doing
is refreshing the container
on top of the virtual machine
and then firing up kind of
the underlying storage layer.
You'll see, in a few
slides, I'm going
to talk a little bit about how
Persistent Disk is actually
used for our
replication solution
for high availability-- and
it's important to kind of tie
that back into the
concept that you see here.
So because we have
this separation
of the virtual machine on the
Compute Engine and this storage
layer, we're able to more easily
move between virtual machines
and do things such as live
migrate across regions,
or in different machine types,
change the characteristics
or parameters of the
machines themselves--
increased storage as well--
without incurring disruption
to your instance.
Now, on the right
side, this is actually
the control plane that's
powering all of Cloud SQL.
And so we have our
metadata servers
that provide us the management
capabilities to roll out
broad changes across the fleet.
And so when we talk about
things like common interfaces,
or any kind of new
capabilities, that we
want to provide to all Cloud SQL
customers-- not just SQL Server
customers-- they're
actually deployed
on the control plane
themselves, such that they can
be accessed by all instances.
So talking about what that
deployment looks like,
and what that
creation looks like,
from the customer perspective.
I wanted to take
a minute talking
about provisioning a SQL
Server instance in Cloud SQL.
And so you'll notice if
you've gone through this flow
that we have the same machine
types that you're able to do
again for Postgres or MySQL.
But if you're familiar
with SQL Server,
you'll know that it can take
advantage of the full breadth
and capability of the
resources that we allocate
to that machine site-- which,
today, is up to 96 virtual CPU
cores, 624 gigs of RAM
and a 30 terabyte SSD.
One key difference here is
that SQL Server in Cloud SQL
only runs on SSD--
you don't have an HDD option.
We found that there's
increased resiliency and less
issues by only providing
that one option.
Now, you can initiate the
creation of this machine,
or a modification of an
existing instance, again,
via the console at UX,
GCloud commands or our API--
much as you would for any
other CloudSQL instance.
Again, the most
important thing here when
you're going and creating that
instance to make it useful
is you want to seed
it with your data.
And so there's a number
of different options
here, one of which
we're going to talk
about a little bit later--
to actually use
transactional replication
to set up Cloud
SQL as a subscriber
and have that kind
of active replication
to bring in the data
with minimal disruption
and minimal downtime.
But of course, you can always
import into Cloud SQL as well.
And so you can import
[INAUDIBLE] native files
and be able to see your data
that way as well, offline.
Now, I mentioned it before,
but once your CloudSQL instance
is in operation,
you have a number
of different other options and
parameters that you can set.
One of which that we've always
gotten a lot of good feedback
from customers on is
about the ability to auto
grow your storage.
And so you don't
have to pre-provision
all of the storage that
you need from the get-go.
Once you do that import--
let's say you're importing a
500 gig SQL Server instance, so
a number of databases that way--
you can set auto grow
on the disk and then not
worry about making sure you
have the correct allocation
for projected growth three,
six, nine months down the road.
Additionally, you can set a
number of different options
just as you would with
SQL Server on prem.
So if you're familiar
with the command using
the stored procedure
for SP_Configure,
you'll know that you can set
a lot of those same settings
in our console,
and via our APIs,
with the different options
that we allow under flags.
That includes collation, which
is now available as well.
For high availability,
we'll talk a little bit
and focus about how
that actually works.
But it's important to
note that, in order
to really get the
most out of Cloud SQL
and really take advantage
of our 3 and 1/2
9 SLA you'll have to select
a regional availability
configuration.
And then make sure that
you pay special attention
to maintenance windows and kind
of the appropriate time for us
to make any changes.
CloudSQL will, of
course, do its best
to minimize any disruption--
have maintenance events happen
as quickly and as
infrequently as makes sense.
But our first priority
is, of course,
always making sure that
the service is both secure
and highly available.
The final point I
wanted to touch on
was the automatic backups.
We get a lot of questions around
how frequent customers can
take backups of their
instance, or DR purposes,
or if they want to then
store them and restore them
into other instances--
either on other clouds
or backed on prem if they're
running a hybrid configuration.
So, by default, you'll
have automatic backups
on a daily basis that you
can set a window when you
want them to actually occur.
These are storage snapshots.
So they're actually
snapshots of Persistent
Disk and should not incur a
performance hit onto SQL Server
itself because you're not using
the database engine to take
the backup, in this case.
For more frequent backups,
you could, of course,
automate a set of manual
backups and use the APIs,
or use GCloud
commands, depending
how you want to
interact with it,
but then you need to manage
the retention of those backups
yourself.
So with the automatic
backups, you
have a seven-day sliding window.
With manual backups, we won't
drop any backup instances--
it's more of a manual retention
management experience.
But when you log
into the instance,
you'll actually see a
list of all of the backups
that you've taken
manual, and you'll
be able to manage them
from there as well.
Of course, you could
always export the data.
We allow a full [INAUDIBLE]
export as well--
and you can leverage that
in conjunction, of course.
But that does leverage the
SQL Server database engine
in that case.
Next topic I wanted to touch
briefly on was analytics.
Folks that are familiar
with SQL Server
are generally interested in also
using the auxiliary services,
such as SQL Server
Recording Studio, Analytics
Studio and
Integrations Services,
all together with SQL Server.
And the best practice
that we found
is actually running
those services separately
in Google Compute Engine.
From there, it's very simple
to connect to your CloudSQK SQL
Server instance via
VPC, and actually
have a reliable and
durable pipeline
that you can create for any data
analytics or transformations
that you want to do.
Native tools will continue
to work as expected.
So if you're using things
like Query Optimizer,
or you're using any
other Microsoft products,
you're more than welcome to
continue to use those, and just
connect to that
CloudSQL SQL instance
and it should
behave as expected.
Now, if you want to use a
slightly different stack,
of course, Google Cloud
has a very robust analytics
ecosystem.
And so you can use tools such as
Dataflow or Cloud Data Fusion,
and just use the standard
connection JDBC connection
string to go and
connect to the CloudSQL
for SQL Server instance, and the
specific database here you're
working with, and then set up
a data pipeline in that manner.
And there's a number
of examples that we
have those in documentation.
In that manner, you
can bring that data
into other destinations--
for example, BigQuery,
if that's something
that you're interested in
and familiar with using for--
and those integrations will
continue to kind of deepen
and become more
robust over time.
I'll talk a little bit
more about that at the end.
The third topic that I wanted
to touch on-- which is, again,
something near and dear
to all of our hearts,
and better to talk about this
proactively than reactively
if something happens--
is security, of course.
So Google Cloud
prides itself on being
a leader in the security space.
And there's actually a number
of Cloud-wide platform features
and capabilities that
we take advantage
of in CloudSQL, both
to ensure consistency
around all of Google
Cloud Services
and also because it is kind
of a best-in-classs solution
that we want to take
advantage of as well.
So Google Cloud, if
you're not familiar,
encrypts both data in
transit and data at rest.
And so at CloudSQL, we
use that in lieu of TE,
just to ensure
that we don't have
that double encryption that
could cause a performance hit.
As a result of
this, though, we're
also able to take advantage
of customer-managed encryption
keys, if you're familiar
with that functionality,
as part of our key
management store.
And so just as you
would set that up
for any other Google
Cloud Service,
you can keep using
that for CloudSQL--
it'll work just the same.
In terms of connectivity,
you have three options.
And really, I've
ranked them here
in order of recommendation
for security purposes.
So number one is private IP.
If you're connecting to other
resources in Google Cloud,
This is actually the
easiest and most secure way
to connect and access
your CloudSQL instance
in your SQL Server database.
You can set that as part of your
VPC or peer-to-VPC networks,
if you so choose.
There's numerous step-by-step
guides and quick starts
in terms of how
to get this done,
and you'll get the best and
simplest experience that way.
Of course, this isn't
always possible,
especially if you're coming
from a different environment,
or connecting from
another Cloud.
And so, for those cases, you
may choose to use a public IP.
And of course, that
brings a new surface area
of security risks and exposure.
And so we provide the CloudSQL
proxy that I've linked to here.
I definitely recommend using
the proxy in conjunction
with public IP
whenever possible,
because it will manager
your SSL connectivity
and settings as well.
And it's also not
going to require
you to authorize any networks,
which is another attack
vector that we've seen increases
exposure to your CloudSQL
instance.
Finally, if you do want to take
on the manual task of managing
all of those aspects,
you're more than
welcome to use public IP.
Those are available--
you'll get an IPv4 address
that you can go and connect to.
And you can connect from
anywhere in the world,
as long as you add your
authorized network as well.
The final point here is in
terms of the login credentials.
So today, if you use
SQL authentication
with SQL Server as
part of CloudSQL,
we actually provide
you a precooked user,
which is SQL Server--
a bit different if you're
familiar with using
SA or Sysadmin in SQL Server--
and it is a subset
of those permissions.
We do this because we want
to ensure the integrity
and security of the service.
And so you'll see we have
a list of functionality
that's available on
our documentation site,
in terms of what can and cannot
be done by the SQL Server user.
But the most important
thing to note
is, besides what's not allowed,
in some of the TSQL commands,
such as the grant
command, you have
to use explicit syntax for
actually granting as customer
roles that we define.
And so I definitely
encourage you
to get familiar with the
syntax and the capabilities
of this user as part
of our documentation
before you just dive right in.
But by and large, you'll
see most of the commands
that you're familiar
with should just work.
So as I alluded to
before, I'm just
going to take a quick
minute here talking
about replicating
Persistent Disk
and how that feeds
into high availability.
So this picture on the
side here kind of serves
the best purpose in terms of
showing you the flow of what
actually occurs.
Our high availability
is a regional solution.
So you have these two
zones in the same region.
The zones are, of course,
separated, as all of our zones
are, and you have your primary
instance here in zone A.
Now, that primary instance
is that compute instance I
was talking about
before, and that's
joined to the Persistent
Disk instance, which
is located in the same zone.
Now, that Persistent
Disk is connected
and replicating to the zone
B Persistent Disk instance.
And they're always kept
in sync by this agent.
And so whenever you're
writing to one instance,
before the write-to-disk
actually succeeds,
it writes to both
Persistent Disk instances.
Now, in front of all this, we
have our IP address and load
balancer that's actually
governing connectivity
to the instance.
So in the case where
one of our agents
notices that there's
a heartbeat failure--
the primary instance
is unavailable--
what will actually occur is that
we will spin down that instance
and then switch over
into that secondary zone
where we've been writing
to Persistent Disk
this entire time.
It will spin up a new VM--
a new container of SQL
Server, essentially--
and mount that second
Persistent Disk to it
and reassign that IP address.
So from an external
perspective, there
should be minimal disruption.
And actually no
connectivity change
because you'll be using
that same IP address
in the connectivity path.
A couple important notes here.
This is not using SQL
Server's native capabilities,
and so it's edition-agnostic.
You can do this with Web
Edition, if you so choose--
or even Express--
and have an HA
configuration, which
is sometimes helpful to keep
your development environments.
Or if you want a
really right size
and go lean with your
SQLServer instances,
you're more than welcome to
and still have HA capabilities
with our SLA backing it.
Finally, I just wanted to
mention that typical times
that we'll see here--
we don't want too
many false positives.
So the heartbeat can actually
take up to 60 seconds for us
to actually determine
if it's a true failure
or a true unavailable event.
At that point, we'll
initiate the switchover.
Generally speaking,
optimistically,
you'll see it under
another minute.
Sometimes it could take
as much as a couple
of minutes on top of
that initial detection.
So just a few minutes later,
and you'll have that failover
experience.
And finally, I just
wanted to call out,
before we switch
over into the demo,
that SQL Agent is
actually running
on all of your CloudSQL
for SQL Server instances.
And so you're able to create SQL
Agent jobs just as you normally
would.
Moreover, all of
the SQL Agent logs
are written out to
our operation stack
with Stackdriver, if
you're familiar with that.
So you can set up
monitoring and triggering
just as you would with
your on-Prem solution.
Now let's go over to
Doug Mahugh and Shashank
to talk a little bit more about
how this is done in practice.
DOUG MAHUGH: Hi,
I'm Doug Mahugh.
And with my colleague
Shashank Agarwal,
we're going to show you how
to migrate an on-premises SQL
Server instance to CloudSQl.
This slide shows
a typical scenario
where you have an
on-premises instance,
you have an application
connected to it,
and we want to migrate
the data to Cloud SQL
without shutting
down our application.
So to do that, we're going
to use SQL Server's data
replication functionality.
As Ori mentioned
earlier, SQL Agent
is enabled by default
in Cloud SQL instances.
And in the demo,
Shashank is going
to show you how to do this
with SQL Server Management
Studio, which you could
use any tool that you're
used to for database
administration in SQL Server.
Cloud SQL for SQL Server
works with PowerShell,
Azure Data Studio-- whatever
you're accustomed to.
So you set up the
distributor node
to coordinate the
transactions, moving data
from the publisher
to the subscriber.
In our example, we'll use
the publisher instance
as the distributor node as well.
But in production scenario, we'd
recommend that be a dedicated
GC instance in the middle.
Once you kick off the
migration, snapshot replication
happens first.
Now, this could take
hours, because this
is moving your entire database,
all the history and everything,
over to Cloud SQL.
However, your application
can continue running,
because those transactions
are being stored,
and those transactions
will be replicated next,
and you'll have an
eventually consistent Cloud
SQL for SQL Server
instance that includes
all of the transactions that
took place during the snapshot
replication.
So this shows what's
happening there.
We're now migrating the
individual transactions over
to SQL Server in the cloud.
And the final step is to just
migrate your application over,
change your connection
string, point it
to Cloud SQL for SQL
Server, and now you're
running in the cloud with
all of your data migrated
and no transactions lost.
So now Shashank is going
to show you, step-by-step,
exactly how to do that.
SHASHANK AGARWAL:
I have a source VM,
which is stored in the
SQL server database.
In your scenario, it can
be an instance outside CCP.
This will be your source.
It will be migrated into
an instance of Cloud SQL.
I have [INAUDIBLE] SQL
2017 standard instance.
So let's get on with migration.
Let me RDP into this.
So as you can see
on this screen,
I have already RDP'd
into my machine.
And I have restored a
[INAUDIBLE] database,
which is one of the
sample databases provided
by Microsoft.
And I would be
using this database
to replicate [INAUDIBLE]
to CloudSQL instance.
And I have connected to my
CloudSQL instance as well.
And as you can see, there are
other databases inside there.
So first step to do this
is to set up distribution.
For convenience purposes, I
am setting up distribution
on the same node where the
primary database lives.
And this can be a
different node as well.
So once distribution
has been enabled,
I'll set up publication.
I am telling SQL Server to
use transaction replication
for my [INAUDIBLE] database.
And I'm then selecting
what articles will
be replicated to the target.
So, essentially, I'm
selecting all the tables.
You'll notice that
[INAUDIBLE] table is disabled,
and this is because it doesn't
have a primary [INAUDIBLE]..
This is something to be
aware of-- that transaction
replication did not work
with non-primary databases.
And next, It's asking me if
I want to filter anything--
I do not.
I'm instructing it to create
a snapshot of the database
to initialize the subscriptions.
And then, I'm providing the
credentials for this publisher
to connect to the distributor.
Since this DCEVM has
not joined any domain,
I'm essentially supplying my
windows credentials for it
to work.
And then, lastly, I'll provide
the name of this publication.
So once this publication
gets created,
we'll see this in the list.
And next, we will
add this distributor
as one of the owners
of the source database.
So I have added distributed
argument as one of the owners.
And now we'll create
a subscription.
So I'm giving it
SQL Server Cloud SQL
instance as my subscriber
to this publication.
Right now, I do not have
any database in this.
So I am instructing it
to create a new delivery.
And as this will
be done, you will
see a new database
generated on the right,
on the left hand side.
And this will be a blank
database at the moment.
But as soon as this
configuration is complete,
then it will start
replicating data
into this
newly-created database.
And once I provide the
credentials, my source
and target systems,
CloudSQLServer
offers connectivity
using SQL Server login.
So let me finish this.
Once I will finish this, they
will start replicating data.
And we can click on this and
view synchronization status
to show what's going on.
Right now, it is saying
we are stopping the agent.
And if I will go into
my [INAUDIBLE] database,
I can see, already, the data
scheme has been replicated.
And if I were instructed to
select some [INAUDIBLE] rows
I'm already observing
that some [INAUDIBLE] rows
are populated [INAUDIBLE] Now
let's see how it is doing.
So that would conclude our demo.
Any further changes
in the source database
will be automatically
replicated into the target.
DOUG MAHUGH: Thanks, Shashank.
And now we're going
to go back to Ori--
he's going to tell us a little
bit about pricing, licensing,
and what's coming next for
CloudSQL for SQL Server.
ORI KASHI: Thanks so
much, Doug and Shashank.
It was really great to see
transaction replication live,
and see how to use CloudSQL
for SQL Server in practice.
So now I'm going to
talk a little bit
about everyone's favorite,
or least favorite, topic--
pricing and licensing.
It's really important to kind
of demystify this and make
it a bit more transparent-- and
that's something that we always
strive to do here at Google.
So breaking this down.
CloudSQL for SQL
Server is really
made up of three
components when you
talk about how we do pricing.
So we've got our
instance price, which--
if you're familiar
with CloudSQL--
both for PostgreSQL and MySQL--
there should be
no surprises here.
So you've got that same
region-specific price that's
comprised of core and memory.
HA Instances are going to be
twice as much on the instance--
mainly because we maintain those
two instances to provide you
that failover so you have
that standby secondary.
And if you have watched any
of the CloudSQL presentations
so far at Next, you'll
know that we've now
released committed
use discounts,
and so those are now
available as well.
So if you choose to prepay,
you do get a discount
both at the one-year and
three-year commitment
levels, which can be
fairly substantial.
It's additionally
important to note
that that commitment is
actually able to be used
across all CloudSQL products.
And so you can go and
use your committed ML,
both for SQL Server and
let's say for PostgreSQL,
if you're interested
in having applications
that leverage databases
of both types.
Now, the unique
part for SQL Server
is, of course, the licensing.
As a partner reseller
for Microsoft,
we do offer the
SQL Server license
that we have to as part
of our CloudSQL offering.
Now, the nuances here
are very similar to what
you see in Compute Engine.
And so the license cost is
charged on a per-VCPU basis.
There is a minimum of
four cores, however.
And so even if you run
a smaller instance,
you will have just the
licensing component actually
be charged at four cores and up.
And this, of course,
varies by addition,
with Express actually having
no licensing cost in that case.
BYOL, unfortunately, is
not available for CloudSQL,
but it is available
for Compute Engine.
So if that is something
that is a requirement
for your organization,
I definitely
encourage you to go
speak to any of the folks
over at Compute Engine, or
reach out to any account manager
or Google support agent,
and they can guide you
through that process.
The final component
here is fairly standard
across all Google
Cloud products.
We have our storage
and networking price.
The interesting parts
here for CloudSQL
are going to be how
we charge backups.
Backups are charged a bit
different than capacity--
actually at a cheaper rate.
But you'll see that kind of
that same HA fee difference
is baked in as well.
So you'll have kind of
capacity being charged twice,
but backups not.
Now, finally, networking.
You'll have IngreS being free
into your CloudSQL instance.
But I would definitely
encourage you
to take a look at kind
of the Egress pricing
so that there are no surprises.
Because based on how you
expect data and traffic
to leave your
Cloud SQL instance,
you may get charged
more or less.
So there's a bunch
of tools online--
a bunch of calculators
and guides--
that will help you navigate and
reduce any complexity there.
So I want to take
just a brief moment
about what's coming next.
We're really excited
here on the CloudSQL team
about what's developing
in the service.
So if you're not familiar,
there's a number of sessions
out there talking about the
Managed Service For Microsoft
Active Directory that we
provide as part of Google Cloud.
We showed this last year
at Next, in conjunction
with CloudSQL for SQL Server.
And that's something that
that integration is actually
coming very, very soon.
So definitely keep
an eye out for that.
It'll be on, of course,
all the typical blog posts
and marketing channels
that we provide here.
Additionally,
there's going to be
a number of new high
availability and DR options
that we're going to be
rolling out as well.
And so I definitely encourage
folks to keep an eye out
for those in the coming period.
Migration improvements.
You've seen a little bit about
how you can manually set up
a transactional
replication, but we
will be providing an
additional and more
streamlined functionality in
conjunction with our database
migration service that
we've also recently
rolled out as well.
And finally, a deeper
analytics integration.
And so we talked a little bit
about how you can set this
up connecting to CloudSQL with
Dataflow and Cloud Data Fusion
to get to BigQuery.
We're definitely focused around
investing in that workflow,
and how we can kind of
streamline that relationship.
So for folks that are familiar
with the Google Analytics
ecosystem, you should have a
much easier time moving forward
using critical products like
SQL Server alongside those tools
as well.
Thanks so much for joining
us today and talking a bit
about CloudSQL for SQL Server.
I definitely encourage
you to check out
all the other great
content here at Next.
If we're the first session
you watch, thank you so much--
and we're flattered.
But there's tons more
to see on the site.
So check out the catalog.
Here we've listed a number of
sessions related to Cloud SQL.
Now, beyond that, of course,
we have a number of sessions
if you're more interested on
Microsoft on GCP in general.
So as I mentioned,
Active Directory
has a session, as well
as Compute Engine.
So lots of great content there.
As well as our
keynotes, of course.
So definitely take a
moment, browse the catalog,
find more interesting
content and hear from more
of our wonderful speakers.
Now, we've also put together
a showcase demo for Cloud SQL.
I definitely recommend
checking it out,
and you can go and
actually see in action
a bit more about how
Cloud SQL operates,
and how some of the replication
and the failover occurs.
And finally, if you want to just
dive in and get more hands-on,
we have Qwiklabs
up for Cloud SQL
at the link you
see here as well.
And so I definitely recommend
checking that out, trying it
out, and seeing if
you can navigate
through all of the
steps and start
using CloudSQL for SQL Server.
And with that, I just want
to say a big thank you
from Doug, Shashank and myself,
as well as the entire Cloud SQL
engineering team and all the
other disciplines that we
work with.
It's a real pleasure to
bring this service to you,
and we really hope
that you find it useful
and enjoy using our service.
Thanks so much.